voilà face à cette contre-offensive
ukrainienne la Russie fait savoir
qu'elle prévoit de faire évacuer plus de
000 civils un repli de Moscou annoncé
dans plusieurs localités à l'exception
de barmouth seul ville où les forces
heureux sont aujourd'hui l'avantage
c'est ce que nous explique tout à
l'heure depuis qu'elle notre
correspondant
mais c'est une exception remarquable
batmouth est une ville importante de la
région de Tonnet que tant que dont le
don-basse et selon les journalistes de
l'AFP qui se sont rendus la ligne de
front traversent maintenant la ville il
y aurait des forces russes dans la ville
de batmouth donc clairement les
Ukrainiens dans cette villa sont en
difficulté et il y a des avancées du
côté des Russes mais ailleurs c'est
toujours la contre-offensive ukrainienne
qui semble avoir le dessus et surtout
sur la ville de Herson qui est il
convient de souligner beaucoup plus
grand de plus importantes que Batman
personne c'est presque 300.000 habitants
avant la guerre backmout 75 si je me
trompe pas et à personne ce sont les
forces russes qui donnent de plus en
plus d'indications d'être sur le point
peut-être même de se rendre le
commandant des forces russes a dit que
les décisions difficiles pourraient être
nécessaires dans les jours à venir